the intensifying war in ukraine has led
to a surprising surge in the demand for
an unusual drug that is rarely used
elsewhere
potassium iodide
the fear of radioactive fallout from
attacks on ukraine's nuclear power plant
is a trigger behind this surge
if such an attack takes place it will
release radioactive iodine in the
atmosphere which can be absorbed by our
lungs or the thyroid gland
hello and welcome to math simplified i'm
dr umar malik in this video we are gonna
talk about what is potassium iodide and
can it be used to protect against
radiation
from a nuclear explosion and who really
needs to take potassium iodide after a
nuclear release
we will talk about what potassium iodide
products are currently available in the
market and then we will discuss about
the side effects of potassium iodide
according to the center for disease
control potassium iodide represented as
ki is a salt of stable iodine with
potassium that can help to block the
radioactive iodine from being absorbed
by the thyroid gland thus protecting
this gland from radiation injury
such an injury can harm the thyroid
gland which produces many hormones that
regulate the body
and can even lead to cancer
the cdc further said that table salt and
foods rich in iodine do not contain
enough iodine to block radioactive
iodine from getting into your thyroid
land
it has advice against using table salt
or foods as a substitute for potassium
iodide
the thyroid gland cannot tell the
difference between stable and
radioactive iodine it will absorb both
potassium iodide will block radioactive
iodine from entering the thyroid
when a person takes potassium iodide the
stable iodine in the medicine gets
absorbed by the thyroid because
potassium iodide contains so much stable
iodine the thyroid gland becomes
saturated and cannot absorb any more
iodine for the next 24 hours
thus the thyroid gland stops further
intake of iodine inside it
so in case there is radioactive iodine
present in the atmosphere due to a
nuclear explosion the thyroid gland will
not absorb it because it is already
saturated
the fda guidance prioritizes groups
based on age which is the primary factor
for determining risk of
radioiodine-induced thyroid cancer
those at highest risk are infants and
children as well as pregnant and nursing
females because of the potential for
sodium iodide to suppress thyroid
function in the developing fetus and the
newborn
the recommendation is to treat them at
the lowest threshold of the drug
anyone over 18 years old and up to 40
years old should be treated at the
slightly higher threshold of the dosage
finally anyone over 40 years old should
be treated with potassium iodide only if
the predicted exposure to the nuclear
fallout is really high
only potassium iodide products that are
fda approved may be marketed legally in
the united states
as of october 2016 the following
potassium iodide drugs are fda approved
and are available without a prescription
iostat tablets
thyrosafe tablets containing 65
milligram stable potassium iodide
thyroshield oral solution containing 65
milligram per milliliter
potassium iodide from arco
pharmaceuticals and potassium iodide
oral solution containing 65 milligram
per milliliter from mission
pharmaceutical company
side effects are unlikely when potassium
iodide is used at the recommended dose
and for a short time
the following are the possible side
effects of potassium iodide
you can get skin rashes and rarely
swelling of the salivary glands
you can experience metallic taste in the
mouth burning and sore throat sore teeth
and gums
symptoms of a cold and sometimes upset
stomach and diarrhea
these symptoms are commonly together
known as iodism
an allergic reaction can have more
serious symptoms
those include fever and joint pains
swelling of parts of body including face
lips tongue throat hands or feet
you can experience trouble breathing
speaking or swallowing freezing or
shortness of breath
all these are very rare and always
remember that severe shortness of breath
requires immediate medical attention
so this was a short video explaining the
effects and side effects of potassium
iodide
i hope you like the content make sure to
press the like button and also make sure
to subscribe to our channel for upcoming
videos
thank you so much guys and see you in
the next video